the other gum Refugee settlement opened
with a few hundred refugees from
Cameroon five years ago
today it houses fourteen thousand
among them is David MBA
he arrived last month with his family
after spending months in the wild
avoiding Rebels and government forces
the shot of gong was paradi up to the
point that where we were in the bushes
we had some cases of bullet
we doubt where whether it is from those
guys the opposition group with the
military
the family arrived feeling traumatized
but unharmed
many other refugees aren't so fortunate
I'm actually arrived
with gunshots wounds some have bands so
the attacks we understand are being
perpetrated by both government soldiers
and also by the ambazonian rebels this
is what the refugees are telling us
long-term residents of the camp like
Vivian Casey said getting into the
settlement doesn't mean an end of
suffering for new arrivals she says
dealing with the neighboring Community
can also be a big challenge
sometimes
people show us
because of a lack of funding monthly
food rations have been cut by half
and few here have the resources and
skills to start a business
with more refugees fleeing the fighting
in English-speaking Cameroon
humanitarian agencies are struggling to
cope last year alone 20 000 new arrivals
have been officially registered by the
United Nations but with donors pledging
less money humanitarian workers face a
funding shortfall of at least 60 percent
officials acknowledge many children here
can be educated as the neighborhood
schools are overcrowded
it's not possible to accommodate all of
them but I think we have done a
significant
we have taken responsibility to involve
a lot of them
places like this are Sheltering about 18
000 refugees from Cameroon
but with humanitarian agencies running
short of funds Aid workers say their
lives could become even more difficult
if the fighting in Cameroon doesn't stop
soon Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera adego